les victimes du terrorisme outre la
manifestation de la vérité qu'à
tente-t-elle de la justice
qu'attend-elle de l'état cette journée
est elle opportune c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soir et pour en
débattre
nous sommes en direct sur ce plateau
avec gérard lopez président de
l'institut de victimologie bonsoir
gérard lopez de ton qui est merci d'être
avec nous sur ce plateau en direct par
skype
patricia correia administratif de
l'association 13 novembre bataclan qui a
perdu sa fille dans cette attente a
atterri bonsoir madame un correia merci
beaucoup des besoins directs avec nous
sur rt france tout d'abord sur
l'opportunité de cette journée patricia
correia ce qu'elle vous semble bien
intitulé la journée nationale des
victimes de terrorisme c'était important
pour vous d'instituer une telle journée
elle est adéquat mais tout à fait
adéquat mais c'est bien sûr que c'est
important on ne peut pas on peut pas
laisser dans l'ombre toutes ces attaques
qui ont lieu durant des années et pour
la mémoire de tous ceux qui ont perdu la
vie pour les blessés pour les rescapés
c'est vraiment pointé du doigt ce que
c'est c'est toutes ces tragédies bien
sûr y compris va mettre finalement tous
les attentats entre guy mais voilà sur
une journée il ne fallait pas dissocier
les attentats parce que ce sont les
attaques depuis 1974
ça ne vous pose aucun problème écoutez
c'est difficile de répertorier tous les
attentats seront 100 cents à 100 mm des
oublis donc on a décidé en face les
gouvernements qui ont décidé que ce
serait depuis 1974
mais bien sûr tous les attentats qui ont
lieu avant cette date on les oublie non
on les oublie pas cessé tout ça c'est
gravé dans la mémoire et mais c'est très
compliqué de remonter dans le temps et
d'avoir tout l'historique gérard lopez
important pour les victimes et leurs
proches justement cette journée de
mémoire de commémoration indispensable
même d'un point de vue psychologique
will un produit psychologique c'est
important de ne pas se sentir abandonnés
parce que vous savez moi ça fait très
longtemps que je m'occupe de gens sic
aux traumatisés donc évidemment des
victimes d'attentats
et souvent on s'intéresse beaucoup à
elle pendant quelques mois et après on
les oublie ça je les joue très très
souvent et c'est très difficile d'être
oublié alors bien sûr il ya aussi
l'indemnisation
la france est un pays où on indemnise
correctement les victimes grâce au fonds
de garantie mais la procédure
d'indemnisation avec des experts qui
parfois remettre en cause ce que vous
dites n'est pas toujours très simple
donc les victimes d'actes de terrorisme
souvent sont encore extrêmement malade
à l'institut nous en avons suivi à peu
près 200 et on a encore certaines qui
sont comme besoin de soin patricia quand
il ya voilà mon envie n'est pas du tout
vous posez des questions personnelles
mais c'est important de vous demander
comment allez vous ces années 1
six ans après cette terrible nuit du
bataclan non non c'est pas six ans ça
fera cinq ans il part dondra donnez moi
ou avec elle dans ma tête et d'écouté
que ce soit le matin qu'il soit la
limite ce soit le dans la journée vous
avez toujours des piqûres de rappel donc
cette blessure qui est profonde qui vous
habite au quotidien ne s'oubliera jamais
uniquement lors de notre dernier souffle
pour tous ceux qui ont perdu un enfant
ou un proche ou un mari bon c'est pas
parce que c'est pas possible d'oublier
je voulais aussi souligné que les
personnes qui ont assisté à ces scènes
de guerre qui sont rescapés ou blessés
c'est pareil à elles ne vont pas bien je
vous ai entendu avec ce monsieur parler
du fond de garantie
alors moi je me dis que le fonds de
garantie il ya vraiment beaucoup de
travail à faire parce que il ya un
manque d'humanité notoire que les
personnes sont expertisés elles
ressortent un peu plus un peu plus
dévastées ggd cas que nous avons au sein
de notre association est vraiment je
pense qu'il faudrait étudier chaque cas
avec soins et pas ce conte se contenter
de se référer à un barème et puis
surtout il faut être accompagné par un
médecin de recours quand on va à l'
expertise
surtout que ce médecin indépendant est
payé par fonds de garantie c'est
indispensable
indispensable parce que c'est une
procédure contradictoire parce que les
médecins qui indemnise qui font
l'évaluation travail pour le fonds de
garantie donc il ya un lien d'intérêt
d'ailleurs souvent ce sont des médecins
qui travaillent aussi pour des
assurances
donc pour que les choses soient
équilibrés contradictoires il faut
qu'ils aient un médecin indépendant qui
défendent la victime et ce médecin
indépendant est une association qui
s'appelle la nam et va pour ça et bien
ce médecin indépendant est payé par
fonds de garantie donc cette
indispensable et c'est une manne
toujours le cas expliquez-nous comment
ça se passe
justement c'est une forme d'une nouvelle
juridiction spécialisée consacrée on se
bomber gerd riss sait comment ça se
passe on ya deux discours comme un
tribunal finalement non c'est pas un
tribunal du tout c'est une le fonds de
garantie c'est un organisme qui situe à
vincennes qui a été créé d'ailleurs par
sos attentats
au début c'était un fonds de garantie
des victimes de terrorisme et maintenant
ça a été élargie à toutes les victimes
à chaque fois que vous prenez une
assurance de biens voitures maisons ou
versés au fonds de garantie je crois 5,6
euros
tout cet argent là est à vincennes et
pour les victimes de terrorisme ça se
passe pas justement c'est pas la loi
c'est pas le tribunal ça se passe
directement par une transaction amiable
seulement je vous dis ce sont des
procédures contradictoires et pour que
ce soit vraiment contradictoire
il faut qu' il y ait un médecin qui
défendent les intérêts de la victime
patricia correa
votre expérience vous avec ce fonds de
garantie
alors moi avec mon expérience n'est pas
très juste encore par rapport à ce que
j'ai subi un ma fille était assise
signer au bataclan
j'ai été très choquée dernièrement parce
que on m'a fait la proposition d'une
somme qui concernaient ma fille par
rapport à son agonie parce qu'elle s'est
vu partir alors évidemment j'ai refusé
cette somme et que je devais partager
avec mon ex mari est la demi-soeur de ma
fille du côté de mon ex mari
donc moi j'ai refusé parce que je trouve
que j'ai subi d'autres préjudices
mais celui que ma fille a subi je refuse
je trouve ça d'une violence extrême
surtout trois jours avant les dernières
commémorations de m'adresser un courrier
en me disant que je dois partager telle
somme et qu' ils ont besoin de ma
signature puisque les autres héritiers
ont accepté alors ça con comme indemnise
parce que ma fille s'est vu agoniser
c'est pas possible
alors voyez ça c'est un donc je dois
être reçus en
l'adresse est évident tout à fait tout à
fait et c est moi je vais vous dire j'ai
eu beaucoup de mal à m'en remettre
c'était mais de toute façon je
refuserais cette somme l'origine dame si
vous saviez que votre fille était au
bataclan
oui et que vous avez eu beaucoup
d'angoissé qu'on a fait ça le préjudice
d'angoissé la wii l'angoissent l'attaqué
subie peut être indemnisé c'est une
victoire
écoutez monsieur qu'on indemnise mon
angoisse d'accord mais pas celle qui
poteau
j'accepte cette espèce est ce que madame
correa vous avez le droit tout
simplement de de contester cette somme
est de demander plus
finalement oui je peux demander plus
mais en fait c'est le libellé qui me
dérange énormément
moi ma vie est dévastée depuis que la
disparition de ma fille qui habitait
encore avec moi elle est assassiné ainsi
que son compagnon d'ailleurs qui lui
avait deux petites filles d'une première
union et c'est une vie qui bascule alors
et je pense que il ya quand même des
choses qui qui sont à étudier et on
n'envoie pas un courrier et trois jours
avant les dernières commémorations la de
novembre 2019 et en vous demandant de
signer ce document
moi je n'ai pas accepté je suis madame
nous avons un avocat tout à fait tout à
fait rien avant et nous et le directeur
du fjt y a demandé à me recevoir en
particulier parce que j'ai fait un petit
peu de de bruit à l'issue de ce de ce
courrier ne cache pas donc j'attends
d'être reçus mais bien d'autres cas il
ya moi je connais des personnes qui qui
vont et qui ont été expertisés elles
sont ressorties de cette expertise
complètement déchiré et à est dévasté
bien plus qu avant d'y entrer
alors ça c'est pas normal c'est pas
normal est tout à fait anormal
absolument et donc maintenant elles ont
décidé d'aller vous savez qu'il ya il ya
eu
nouvelle procédure maintenant on peut
déposer sa devant un juge alors le
sommeil après c'est ce à quoi on faisait
allusion rendez pas durer dix sont là le
fameux gimat une nouvelle juridiction
consacré aux victimes du terrorisme
c'est bien ça vaut ma question tout à
l'heure elles ont bien au rendez-vous et
mais vous savez je ne sais pas si malgré
ces de cette nouvelle procédure
les gens vont pouvoir obtenir gain de
cause je n'en sais rien voyez attendons
voyons comment ça va se passer comme si
vous êtes bien accompagné par un avocat
compétent dommage corporel pour les
victimes je le dis il ya une association
nationale des avocats de victimes
s'appellent la nada vie donc pour ceux
qui n'en n'ont pas un il ya des avocats
spécialisés et il ya des médecins
spécialisés pour accompagner les
victimes
il faut passer par des professionnels
c'est clément on est complètement démuni
après cinq ans et a aujourd'hui dont
journée on disait un nationale de
commémoration clairement vis-à-vis de
l'état vous vous sentez sont tenus en
tant que que victime
alors si vous voulez je ne sais pas à
quel est le rôle de l'état par rapport à
cette trop d'options qui est le fonds de
garantie j'en sais rien madame aucun
peut-être de connaître davantage
effectivement la vérité déjà sur ce qui
s'est passé on il va y avoir un procès
on en parlera en 2021 également tout
simplement de maintenir une lutte
intense contre le terrorisme peut-être
le rôle de l'état c'est justement la
justice parce que la justice est
régalien
le fonds de garantie sur le terrorisme
pour l'entente du numéro on parle
d'indemnisation parle de soutien aux
victimes directes
oui aux employés et aux victimes
directes
là le rôle de l'état c'est d'avoir créé
justement une juridiction ce que la
juridiction c'est l'état le fonds de
garantie c'est c'est pas l'état du tout
non c'est un domaine à part mais en ce
qui concerne le rôle de l'état si vous
voulez nous on travaille beaucoup en
dans le domaine associatif pour pour
diverses raisons
par exemple nous nous avons des demandes
de la part des délices et quelquefois
nous allons nous ne nous échangeons avec
des étudiants des collégiens il ya
certains et certaines maisons d'arrêt
qui nous demande de venir aussi pour
discuter avec des des détenus mais papa
d'et radicaliser pour d'autres détenus
donc on nous y allons là l'état va faire
un musée et donc c'est un travail de
longue haleine
donc on travaille aussi avec eux on
assiste à beaucoup de réunions qu'est-ce
qu'il ya d'autres os il ya madame
hidalgo aussi qui on est on est on
prépare aussi un mémorial qui sera sur
paris sur le lieu est pratiquement
choisit donc il ya beaucoup d'action qui
sont qui sont menées 1 dans dans divers
domaines et puis et puis la mémoire le
travail de la mémoire c'est très
important parce que s'ils les ont doit
transmettre ça fait partie de notre
histoire ça doit on le doit transmettre
à toutes ces nouvelles générations
ne jamais oublier donc on a beaucoup de
travaux en commun avec avec le
gouvernement si la comptable il
s'agirait importante c'est que l'état a
créé aussi dit centre de psycho
traumatologie en france qui n'existait
pas avant
donc maintenant il ya dix centres de
psycho traumatologie avant il y avait qu
l'institut de victimologie on est
toujours là et puis il ya d'autres
centres qui sont en dehors de ces dix
ans par exemple à poitiers je connais un
médecin qui a ouvert un centre avec
l'hôpital pour soigner les psycho
traumatisés donc ça c'est le rôle de
l'état et il l'a fait même si c'est à
mon avis pas suffisant et je dois saluer
la mairie de paris qui nous a donné un
million de francs pour aménager le
centre du psycho trauma de l'institut de
victimologie et on est débordés en
listes d'attentes donc le rôle de l'état
c'est aussi de faire en sorte que les
victimes puissent bénéficier de soins
par des gens bareigt spécialisés
oui spécialisés c'est très important
parce que moi je suis allé trois fois
chez d&g des thérapeutes et finalement
je me suis aperçu que c'était inutile et
que ses fins j'ai l'impression de perdre
mon temps où elles ne sont pas formels
faire madame sont pas formés
donc je d'être dans le milieu associatif
si vous voulez moi ça donne un sens à ma
vie
nous menons un combat et nous
travaillons tous ensemble et ça nous
permet aussi de tenir debout parce que
c'est vrai que avec des vies qui ont
basculé comme ça c'est sais c'est pas
toujours facile de donner un sens à sa
vie et de et continuer patricia par ea
il va y avoir organisé le procès de ces
attentats du 13 novembre l'année
prochaine en 2021 procès d'ampleur qui
va durer six mois comment vous vous
l'appréhendez ce procès ce que vous en
espérez beaucoup bon alors ça vous savez
ce sont des questions qui sont chaque
personne a un ressenti différent il faut
qu'il y ait un procès c'est évident mais
si je dois vous parler pour mon cas
personnel je n'en attends pas grand
chose parce que ça changera rien à ma
vie mais c'est important pour la nation
et puis pour l'histoire qui est un
procès mais je pense que je suis pas
certaine que ça va nous apporter
beaucoup de d'éléments phrase très
compliqué c'est très compliqué
l'histoire du procès et j'ai peur j'ai
peur très peur que ce soit un grand show
médiatique parce qu'un procès qui dure
six mois c'est c'est quelque chose de
c'est la première fois je crois je suis
même pas s'il ya eu des procès qui ont
duré six mois
c'est avec quelque chose de jeu dire que
le monde entier va eva eva va être je
dire va avoir les sens le regard sur le
vers nous et qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on
en attend de ce procès parce que
regarder pourquoi un des principal
cerveau de ces attentats s'appelle about
il est pas là donc on va juger
on va juger d'aider des gens dès qu'ils
ne sont plus de ce monde
est-ce que ça va nous vous avancez à
beaucoup de choses je n'en sais rien
sincèrement c'est c'est un sujet qui est
très compliqué et je pense que chaque
personne a son propre ressenti que ça va
rouvrir des blessures pour beaucoup de
vue strictement gérard lopez votre avis
pardonnez moi ce qui convient à votre
avis de psychiatres sur ce procès madame
coria nous à voile a livré son avis elle
a dit c'est le mien il ya différentes
réponses vous en tant que professionnel
avec une vue peut-être de l'extérieur et
la vue du professionnel il est
indispensable ce procès c'est la loi
toute façon ils ont commis des crimes
faut bien sûr les victimes juste là pour
les victimes
ça peut être très difficile parce que ça
va rallumer des plats vous savez les
victimes et ont dans la tête
un film horrible et magnétoscopes est
très très fragile et plus on parle
d'attentats plus on revit les choses là
dit tout à l'heure elle
dis très clairement il se passe toujours
quelque chose qui remet le couvert à
l'adisq roi quelque chose comme ça et
bien si moi ça va être très difficile à
digérer c'est exact et il faudra que les
victimes soient soutenus par des psys
oui justement même qu'on vienne nous
parler de ce cirque médiatique
est ce qu'il veut il peut justement bien
sûr ouvrira encore davantage la plaie et
bien entendu quand on allait vers le
centre du psycho trauma d'instituts de
victimologie en 95 c'était après les
attentats il y avait une chaîne de télé
je crois que c'était lci
elle s'appelait pas comme ça à l'époque
qui sont génériques c'est l attaque de
l'avion qui s'était posé à marseille
avec des morts etc
le gign ce sont les victimes qui ont
obtenu qui retire ce film parce que
c'était pour eux quelque chose de
terrible revivait constamment les choses
donc certaines victimes qui vont un peu
mieux vaut risque de voir les troubles
flambé à cause de ce procès où quand on
voit la télévision évidemment des
attentats ou des choses comme ça très
difficile
le fait de connaître peut-être un peu
mieux la vérité même si on la connaît en
grande partie est ce que quand même ça
peut y aura beaucoup de surprises il y
aura pas beaucoup de surprises
vous savez évidemment quand c'est un un
crime horrible une disparition
fournirait savoir la vérité c'est
fondamental mais là on la connaît la
vérité pourquoi six mois parce que le
dossier est énorme et calgary
je crois qu'en milliards 2,1 milliards
de pages on est ok nîmes effrayant
donc évidemment c'est ça qui va prendre
du temps c'est d'étudier le dossier
alors justement on parlait de vérité
aujourd'hui à une association vous le
savez peut-être de victimes de
l'attentât de nice en l'occurrence 1
promenade des anges qui elle n'a pas
voulu participer à ces hommages qui a
boycotté cet hommage de commémoration la
colère
savez c'est normal les victimes un des
signes les plus évidents c'est qu'ils
sont en colère pour ça que souvent on a
du mal à les supporter parce qu'elles
sont en colère et c'est bien justifiée
je vous faire justement écouter la
raison de leur colère si on peut écouter
le communiqué de cette association
promenade des anges
monsieur françois-xavier lauch chef de
cabinet du préfet des alpes maritimes au
moment de l'attentât et placé sous le
statut de témoin assisté
sa responsabilité est directement
engagée du fait des réunions
préparatoires au dispositif de sécurité
du 14 juillet 2016
l'accès aux pièces en tant que partie
civile nous est refusée par la juge
voilà plus d'un an que la délégation
interministérielle de l'aide aux
victimes n'est pas venu participer au
comité local d'aidé aux victimes
le jeu chez mama qui avait promis via la
presse l'audition de nombreuses parties
civiles n'en aura entendu qu'une seule
avant de quitter son poste
nous sommes bien loin des 150 audition
annoncé gérard lopez réagir vivement ça
vous étonne
bah ça m'étonne pas ce que les avocats
ont un accès aux dossiers normalement
vous comprenez cette salle où je
comprends cette colère bien sûr c'est ce
que je disais les victimes se sentent et
sont souvent oublié d'où l'importance de
cette cérémonie
mais elle peut paraître un petit peu
légère par rapport à la souffrance que
les gens ressentent bien sûr ce vêtement
mais bon c'est impossible de suivre les
deux et ça se mesure pas la souffrance
dans ces semences et ce quelque chose de
certaine madame ça se soigne
oui face à ce soit devant nous qui
jamais monsieur sy non non non non je
dis qu'on a ajouté que nous avons sur le
coeur de souffrance et jamais nous
n'oublierons ski ski et qu'on nous
arracher nos enfants à la vie parce que
jamais c'est évident mais pas très sakho
réajustement pardonnez moi je vous ai
coupé m'a redonné moi est ce que vous
vous évidemment on comprend votre
émotion et on en est bien désolé sur ce
plateau en tout cas est-ce que vous
éprouvez de la colère de là est né et
vous avez voilà vis-à-vis comme cette
association même de l'état qui n'a
peut-être pas pu empêcher protéger ses
citoyens ou tout simplement envers les
meurtriers eux mêmes alors sachez sachez
que nous sommes trente familles qui qui
qui nous avions porté plainte contre
l'état
il y a quelques années maintenant alors
la première fois nous avons été déboutés
nous avions fait appel
c'était surtout des personnes qui
avaient perdu quelqu'un au bataclan et
la deuxième fois nous avons aussi été
dégoûté alors de toute façon c'est vrai
parce que moi je pense qu'il ya eu des
failles de l'état j'ai toujours pensé
surtout que le bataclan était ciblé deux
après les attentats du caire en 2009
donc il ya quand même quelques il y a
beaucoup de dhombres de sueur sur ce
sujet et je ne sais pas si on en aura un
jour la réponse mais nous nous avons
fait ce cette démarche
voilà vous savez on peut aller plus loin
une fois qu'on a épuisé tous les recours
en france on peut aller à la cde h la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
merci envie car oui le monde f1 très
rapidement sophie coriace que nous
arrivons à la fin très rapidement s'il
vous plaît non pas de mot de la fin mais
merci patricia correa merci gérard lopez
d'avoir été avec nous pour parler de
tête journée nationale de commémoration
des victimes d'attentats merci à vous
deux